identifying as a good woman nowadays is
a bit difficult men do test women I've
been tested by men one out of three
women has an STD one out of three women
has had an abortion majority are really
not going for men that's not monogamous
then why they fight for man to be
monogamous
um so
um really good question how does a guy
identify a good woman I think mostly
it's looks but that's not how they do it
but I think it's about it it's about a
Vibe actually it's about an energy and
it's about respect
if a woman you know can really show this
man that she respects him okay but in
the beginning that's challenging because
you know you're on a first date I think
the first indication is usually looks
what was the second question bro what
percent of women do you think are good
women ooh in this day and age yes I
think women are so confused
it's really hard to say I would say good
woman what do you mean by that what I
mean by that I think a good woman is
probably less than 10 these days okay I
think a good woman is a healed woman so
I feel like the reason why there's not
much good women out there is because no
one really knows how to heal and recover
from their past relationships and
traumas and so they bring those women
not be like broken to begin with yeah
100 yeah yeah yeah yeah and so I feel
like they found ways to heal and they've
like taken time out to isolate
themselves and I feel like maybe then
they will be able to move forward and
find the right partner for the right
reasons and I feel like
um why the percentage may be so low is
because no one's really willing to do
the hard doc Shadow work what do you
mean Shadow because whenever I hear like
this stuff no no offense like the shadow
work the healing I always hear it like
nothing yeah like never like real
concrete steps of like so if you're a
woman you're trying to improve what do
you what do you do so you're trying to
select your ego you know the dark side
of you beside that you don't show anyone
but it can come out so you're trying to
like kind of tame that and work on your
insecurities and all the things that you
don't want people to see okay and so you
can how do you how do you work on them
so I mean for me personally I write down
I I Journal stuff so I write things down
my fears or things I don't like about
myself or that I want to change or that
I feel I'm ex I'm expression maybe in
the wrong way and so I try and like find
ways to fix that and just you know work
so how are you like held you know like
if I want to lose weight you go to a
personal trainer and they say like good
bad like how do you hold yourself
accountable to do it doing research
finding a routine making sure that
you're consistently keeping up with
things and maintaining that process
yeah this just kind of sounds like
nothing to me yeah okay so I'm just I'm
sorry
no no but like when I whenever I hear
girls like talk about this
it just sounds like okay I write in my
journal
um I and I Google things online and I
try to be better but there's no like
accountability like anyone keeping you
in check to like show that you are
getting better I think most people
um don't have anyone to keep them in
check when there's a will there's a way
if you really want to change then you
will make sure that you get that [__]
done like so so if you're talking to a
guy and he says like okay you you said
you I was broken before I'm Healed now
like what steps would you show them that
I am now healed
um you're able to be more compassionate
and less judgmental and more open and
vulnerable okay so how could you prove
that you are just by being just by being
that I mean I feel like time will tell
okay you know okay because like I was
just thinking like if you want to
concrete steps it's like married mentors
maybe a male therapist like that sort of
thing I just never hear whenever I hear
women's self-improvement it's always
like be more confident write in a
journal and Google things no no fat like
respectfully yeah I just don't
understand but you know what's crazy
I've tried personally I've tried therapy
and I've and the first time I tried it I
walked out in an anger and rage and I
was like human and the second time I
told her it's not gonna work I don't
think you can fix my problems I agree
with you I've been to the therapist
before and I just thought therapy was
like stupid for the most part and now
I'm in school for psychology and I see
the women that are therapists and
they're nuts I would not go to therapy
yeah I feel like they don't care they're
just getting paid to do what they need
to do they don't give a [__] so yeah
yeah but but I do think there are some
male therapists that are helpful mostly
like male
um what do you think about that
um I've never had a male therapist and I
wouldn't go to a male therapist because
I need to I need to connect with a woman
that's like you know what I mean like
women's
no not that's broken like me not
necessarily but I feel like women
connect easier no I think I think women
looked at comfort and then look to solve
problems and that's why I don't think
therapy works when they're women most of
the time there's exceptions because like
men like women are just gonna comfort
you they're going to tell you what you
want to hear where men will tell you how
to fix it but the problem is like women
we never want to fix it like actually
fix it interesting yeah it's true I had
a male therapist actually before the I
had a therapist for eight years I'm not
in therapy anymore but the first four
years was it was a woman in the last
four years of man and I'm not in therapy
anymore and I'm like I'm good now but
that's because it was a man not a woman
because when I was a woman they would
just sit there and soak in all my issues
and all the problems and there was never
a solve or a solution no one was trying
to help me and then trauma what's her
like and they call everything trauma
everything you know everything's abuse
or trauma I'm like what the [__] what do
you mean I don't believe in trauma I
don't believe in trauma either it's a
bunch of yes it's just so that
psychologists can make money off yeah
well I do I do believe in like War
trauma like from War what do you mean
like I think if a guy goes to war and
sees some like sees things that's real
trauma but the way we use it today my
ex-boyfriend cheated on me my it's just
everything's strong everything but can I
say something don't you think there's
something called unhealed baggage that
we'd be carrying with us because we
haven't overcome how we felt in the last
relationship you should just get over it
okay
yeah yeah I think that we should quit
whining our great grandmothers had to
deal with them like they used to have
plagues and [__] getting cheated on like
this is just the example I'm using but
most of modern day problems are really
nothing compared to like 100 200 years
ago you could get the plague and like
die you know that'd be traumatic being
afraid you know and you're right you
know what because I feel like personally
I've been through so much I haven't had
real therapy and I'm I'm strong I'm I'm
still going you know what I mean it's
not affecting me maybe it is in a way
but it's not in intervening in my life
yeah strong strongly the reveling in the
story is what a lot of the women
therapists were using Penelope is my
daughter and they were um you know
really listening to your story and and
giving a lot of emphasis to it like you
were really overweight and the
therapists were like no no don't don't
talk about it don't don't try to help
her lose weight and I'm like what do you
mean like we've got to fix this problem
like what's the plan it was so
frustrating oh so they wouldn't try to
solve like how big were you I was 300
pounds shut up I was 300 pounds you look
great
foreign
how did your life change from going from
300 pounds to I don't know what you are
now but clearly not so I lost 130 pounds
actually wow and you're tall too yes
what are you six two no five nine and a
half oh [__] you look you look tall as
heck okay
um but basically I was you know I think
part of the problem was because I was in
therapy for so long and I nobody told me
in therapy that there was anything wrong
with me and I had depression I had
anxiety I had suicidal thoughts and I
was not I didn't have a good
relationship with my father at the time
and nobody was saying oh you need to
lose the weight your life will be better
if you just do that nobody they tried to
give me medication they tried to give me
pills they tried to put me in more
therapy and it was until one day I
looked in the mirror and I'm like I
don't want to be like this anymore I
don't want to feel like this anymore and
to be honest the body positivity
movement crushed my soul and told me oh
you should be you know you're beautiful
no matter what size you are you're
beautiful no matter you know how much
you weigh you're beautiful no matter
what you eat you can eat anything you
want and you're gorgeous go girl and I
thought it was okay wow I thought it was
okay because no one said anything and I
could be sitting here if 300 pounds
enough I didn't make the decision to say
Penelope you need to get your butt off
the couch and work out fix your diet fix
your mental health fix everything and
now I'm perfectly fine no meds just
naturally all natural what do you do you
think that contributes to 70 of women
being overweight in the U.S completely I
completely think that
yeah go ahead no I just think that I
think that the fact that people are
obese and that they make all these
excuses for oh I'm obvious because of
the summer because you can lose weight
no matter what anyone can lose weight
it's just about finding the right way to
do it and what do you think of the women
that say we need like representation and
magazines
um we need fat chicks on the cover
Victoria's Secret fashion show it
proposes me so it repulses me to see
that because you've been there it does
because I've been there and not only
that but you are showing thousands and
millions of women in the world that it
is one okay to be unhealthy too okay to
be slowly killing yourself and three
okay to go outside and dress
provocatively with your rolls out
I was a plus-sized model right in the
90s you were a plus-sized mom in the 90s
yeah is there anything wrong with a
little plus-sized girl yeah because what
about the people that actually what
about the people that actually can't
lose weight
but what about people that actually but
they mentally can't say that for the
rest of their life they're going to be
that same size they need some they need
some empowerment because otherwise they
could you know commit suicide or
something do you go to it do you go to
um uh basketball game and look to see
like an NBA game all right what do you
guys have since football right football
here you go to a football game here and
you try to see average football players
average like below average football
players play football here when you go
to a professional game do we see them no
do you do you go there to see that oh uh
well no so then right on the cover of
magazines which is supposed to be the
epitome of beauty do we have below
average women on it right
like why like why is that why do we need
that
I I feel ashamed I don't like it I don't
want to see it I think you're right
about the fact that they're doing it too
because you know if you want to talk
about the health system and the way the
world's set up they don't want people to
come out of a BCE right so they're gonna
make it look like it's okay they don't
want you to so so why wouldn't we have
healthy people on the Mac in front of
Mag I'm not saying like because they
didn't want that yeah yeah but you said
we need that earlier no but I was saying
that for the for the people that don't
that actually I think in my head I'm
thinking for the people that actually
because a person that actually cannot
overcome obesity and for the rest of
their life till the age of 60 70 they're
still going to be overweight those
people are probably feeling yes like
they're they're feeling okay they're you
know they're empowered
would you rather be in power than commit
suicide because people think oh look at
you but when you're when you're
overeating you're slowly committing
suicide exactly my mother did it wow she
died wow like 500 calls of death was
severe obesity and then when my daughter
started getting the weight I was
freaking out right and so that's why
we're on a mission and yeah but don't
you think there's a certain level though
obviously there's obesity and there's
because I feel like the modeling world
has always
promoted unhealthy unhealthiness and
that makes sense even the slim women
slimming women was like six and like
very small do you know what I'm saying
that would it looked like they weren't
eating exactly
I'm Marilyn Mon
Roe was very slim and they wouldn't eat
or they wouldn't do something just to
fit in a certain calories you know what
I'm saying I mean there are some but I
just maybe for like for like an early
2000s
we looked at the last like
like women on the covers were just
beautiful what's the average weight you
would say uh let's see I don't know off
the top of my head as a Ford Model the
the girls who are in straight size
modeling they were size four and that's
because the samples are made in a size
four
and so it's all four different from uk4
it is a bit Yeah like more like a two I
think it'd be more like a two two the
average the average woman she's gone
okay the average woman is 5'4 I'm in
America and I can do UK in a second five
four twenty years old and weighs 170
pounds oh what's that in stone please
[Music]
average Stones I don't actually know
indeed but that's overweight I would say
that that average that she just quoted
would be a 12 stone 12 12.14 okay
because I would think that average is
between 8 to 12. I think if you're in a
good in shape 12 there's good In-Shape
12 women
and you think about that then we're
talking obesity you know what I'm saying
um it's BMI yeah to be honest sorry uh
to be honest it depends I think like
around 10 years ago it used to be way
different I think now they kind of
raised it you know yeah yeah 10 years
ago I went I don't know I was like 65
kilos I don't know what that is sorry
and and Stones it must be like 165 in
um in America 2.2 to one yeah and they
would already say oh you should try to
lose weight you know for your height
whatever now if you look at that they're
like yeah you're perfect you can be a
model so it really changed in the last
decade I would say really it did so it
was about around 10 years ago was there
plus size models is that a new thing
I'll be honest um definitely we're on
America's Next Top Model I mean it
wasn't that as common though but I
definitely I I used to watch Tyra Banks
anyone yeah yeah anyone yeah but they
weren't like this they weren't like the
yeah like you see today they're just
kind of like they're like tens big boned
all right yeah ten is not big no Ten's
not big
but this one I'm saying for the modeling
yeah but again it's like when you go to
an NBA game I want to see good
basketball players like it's supposed to
be the epitome of beauty yeah like now
we're rewarding average like I don't
want to see average chicks like faces on
I'm not saying plus plus but she's a
good size 12 with good Curves in that
Amanda want to see that we don't really
want to just see slim girls all the time
I'll be honest I believe that I believe
that some men like that I really do it's
typical to be honest it's typically
broke man because if you look at
original yeah yeah if you look at like
it like half like I'm just I
there's no fans but no no it's like when
you rich man what do they have on their
arms
but the only reason why they have slim
women is because the slim women are in
the higher echelons of places where the
other women no not in view no let's not
talk about beauty only I'm talking about
venues certain venues certain places
that they get to go to certain women
can't get to go there okay Leonardo
Capri of he wanted a big chick he
couldn't find one no he couldn't find
one but I'm saying in certain the plate
the venue the events no events he goes
from Instagram come on
they could get any chicken yeah they can
but but do you think Leonardo this guy
named bear girls DMS just hollering
girls in the DMS
no I think he'll I think he'll pick like
uh
he won chick uh the Hadid
the model yeah I don't know what I say
it's like if you look at the richest
most successful man they they typically
have slim women I'm saying if you're
looking at the richest parts of events
and venues you've made fair whatever and
in America Manhattan whatever if you go
to the upper echelons or places you know
what I'm saying do you really think that
the only reason they're with slim
beautiful women is because of the events
they go to no but I'm saying because of
the environment that they're in okay
that was because that would that is
society's ideal of a beautiful woman
that's why and so I feel like the plus
model came in when people started
complaining that there wasn't a
selection of varieties why is it that
all around the world they like young
beautiful slim women everywhere even in
different societies with completely
different cultures please
please do not bring out this one
fringent tribe in Africa everyone brings
up but it's like they're it's such a
small percentage of the world well
Africa there's something Africa they
bring up some tribe in Africa assist
that likes the fat women but it's a very
very I've done this commentary but if
you think ahead but if you think about
is the motherland
continuous
me coming no you know deep down you know
that men like slim women in general I'm
gonna be honest I don't think they do
I'm gonna be honest and I'm gonna say
this coming from
being a black man okay if I'm talking
about being a black man or from a black
perspective of I feel like majority of
us men like thicker women okay well and
and even me Jordan
but you keep talking about celebrity men
that are going to be around to hire
women that are that certain women I'm
from a one person not a family my dad my
dad my dad is a top one percent earner I
grew up around in a wealthy neighborhood
I'm telling you they do not put fat
chicks on their arms in high class in
high class society and celebrities want
people with the option to not have a fat
chick on their arm do not all right well
even like what's having a conversation
the other day with with a woman and she
was a slim woman she's from America as
well so American
um I think like Atlanta or whatever and
she said when she was slim she was only
getting approached by white men okay she
put she put on a lot of weight no not a
lot of weight but these tips got body
whatever blah blah now she's getting
approached by a lot of black men which
is what do you get on what I'm saying if
you if you look at it on on the Democrat
thing which which successful black men
that we know are dating well we're only
going to talk about successful yeah
because those are the men with options
broke men don't have as many options as
rich men definitely have options they do
not have as many options as Richmond so
if you look at the men with the most
options to look okay so if we want to
see what women want we got to look at
the women with the most options who do
the most beautiful the youngest most
fertile women pick if you want to look
at men what do men like we have to look
at the men with the most options because
it's not really fair to say oh I like
fat chicks if I make you know ten
dollars an hour at Taco Bell right like
you can't you don't guess
yeah no I I get that but obviously if
you're going if you're talking about
celebrity celebrities are guided but I
didn't just say celebrities I'm from I'm
my dad is in like he's a top one percent
earner I grew up with 10 siblings in a
10 bedroom mansion in a community where
many people made that amount of money
yeah so so I've been around a successful
wealthy man and they don't put fat
chicks sometimes they they do get fat
later but they don't appreciate that you
know what I mean so yeah but I hear what
you're saying what I'm saying the reason
these men obviously gonna go for similar
because they're around that's what you
being in the top one percent and being
in in this neighborhood okay it allows
you to see different things together
no if you do have obviously if you do
have money a lot of people with money
are in the gym they do it because they
have more time on their hands to do
other things you get what I'm saying no
they have less time
you think they'll have less time people
absolutely have less time
no no I could tell you 100 but also I
think the reason that a lot of woman and
are Slimmer and why do you think more
successful men want women who are
Slimmer it's because it's healthier for
them like their risk for getting you
know diseases at an older age their risk
for having pregnancy risks are much
lower if they're not overweight yeah so
why would a man choose a woman if he
wants to marry them if they're going to
die at 50 if they're going to die at 70
if they're going to have their
children's gonna have to be at risk for
birth risk I mean I would never want
that and I don't think I don't think men
want that like when men are looking for
wives they're not looking for like women
who are going to have risks and we even
saw how for you how your bad habit
passed on to her and that's like if you
have a bad habit yourself you will pass
it on to your kids and then it's another
problem that your kid like because I had
the same my mom used to feed me like
Pop-Tarts and stuff when I was a kid and
I and my mom was pretty big and then she
ended up like losing all the weight
um and she told me like she literally
did it for my dad
um and
um yeah I have a sugar addiction to this
day you know what I mean so it's like
bad habits pass from like the parents to
the kids exactly and sugar is more
addictive than cocaine yeah crazy yeah I
do miss Pop-Tarts they make healthy pop
darts but they're really not healthy
they're still junk food no I said I
don't like I like the cinnamon one
I wanted the complete opposite direction
like total Neurosis I got my bachelor's
master's degree in nutrition I helped
thousands of people lose weight regain
their health and it was almost like her
Rebellion so her choice to gain autonomy
through overeating and ill health was
almost you know well it was just so so
crazy for me because I was so happy I
thought you said you were overweight as
a kid I was but as an adult what were
you doing my whole life until I was like
15 I was like rebelling against her I
was like I'm gonna eat all the junk food
so I'd go to my friend's house and stuff
my face with pizza and then their moms
would call her and be like oh my gosh is
your daughter okay she's eating like a
box of pizza and like my whole box of
goldfish wow and I would just do that
and then I come home and I would never
like her cooking even though she's the
best cook I know but like I would I just
rebelled my whole life yeah it was
terrible uh James says there's a
difference between fit and thick men
want fit women
um puffy I'm in Las Vegas and I see
plenty of women from Africa I'm black
this is Cap we like thin women
and then I think there was one more I'm
just gonna do really quick uh lady in
the red is telling the truth I've lost
67 pounds my life is better off these
plus size influencers are lying to
people example lizzo yeah what do you
think of lizzo so I actually recently
did a video on this um I set up Podcast
but basically lizzo is portraying
something that is terrible for a young
woman and then you have thousands of
young women saying oh my gosh those are
so beautiful everyone should be like
lizzo and then you have all the fat
people looking at lizzo feeding off of
her positivity her body positivity and
why does she lead with it too like she's
her brand like make people sick yeah
nobody would talk when Adele was
overweight nobody really spoke about her
wait because she didn't lead with her
you know they did speak about it when
she lost the weight right they were like
oh we can't believe you lost weight we
hate you now like we don't like you like
you did this for for social media and
it's like what yeah what about doing
this to save her life why aren't more
people supporting right women losing
weight that's what real body positivity
because we know the whole world is lazy
the majority of people so that it fits
well also the food industry benefits the
food industry and the medical industry
to have more overweight people because
then you have more surgeries than you
have more medications being handed out
then you have more depression anxiety
suicide I mean the divorce rates you
know it's right it's insane right no I
mean honestly like one time I was at
work and these guys were like like
clowning on women over 200 pounds
they're like oh I would never do but
they didn't know I was because I like I
don't look like I didn't look like I was
over 200 right and literally I ended up
like losing a bunch of weight because I
was so embarrassed and then it was the
best thing that ever happened to me I
ran a marathon because I was like I'm
done I'm done with this like
run a marathon yeah or
to exercise too like I remember being in
that place I went to the doctor's office
actually and that's when I started I
they were like your triglycerides are up
your your aristic heart disease type 2
diabetes and you know if you don't start
now you are gonna die very like slowly
but soon and I was terrified I was like
what just from being fat I was wow how
long did they say you had
I'm just curious
no they weren't like you're gonna die
tomorrow but they weren't curious like
how long do 300 pound people live I
don't know do you know I don't know the
stats on that yeah I know but they they
definitely have a higher risk of
cardiovascular disease which is a number
one killer they have a higher risk of
cancer they definitely will develop
Diabetes Type 2 and other diseases that
are 100 professional there's that
influencer that just like dropped dead
the other day because she was obese and
like she would literally always be
eating and doing mukbangs then she died
I'm not surprised why do you think she
died everyone you know no they said and
then they say like when obese people go
to the doctor and they say to lose
weight that they're like not listening
to them but I'm like well I mean I'm not
a doctor but you might want to like
watch what you're but even doctors are
lying to people now saying oh it's okay
to eat like cheeseburgers they can't
weigh you they can't weigh you either
even that and it's like you guys why are
you lying to these people who actually
some some people who actually want to be
helped are being lied to yeah oh just do
the keto diet oh just do the paleo diet
it'll be fine that's not a long-term
Solution that's not a lifestyle right
the doctors aren't really even trained
in nutrition they don't know how to help
and the business model isn't set up for
them to support their their patients so
it's the whole model is flawed and we
really need to get smart and get
responsible and to be clear about what
we're putting in our thoughts in our
minds and in our in our mouths literally
they said as an African woman Zimbabwean
we are curvy there's a big difference
between being curvy and overweight you
can be thin and curvy um and just big
big uh and then there's another one that
was from interracial marriages our
relationships for black men Community we
value bigger women because they make for
better sex partners uh marriage is
different requirements for than sex my
thin women or my thin woman felt like
she was too pretty to fulfill my sexual
requirements
um okay so how did you say how does a
man identify a good woman
I would say that a man identifies a good
woman if she's one healthy and fit
that's important okay especially for
childbearing and I'd say number two if
she has Traditional Values if she
believes in being submissive if she
believes in being feminine she she she
she loves I'm going to answer that
question
we're gonna get to the men okay
don't worry
it was just whoever's sitting you know
um and then I think if she wants to cook
if she's okay cleaning she wants she's a
homemaker she would love to you know
have children and take care of them and
be a housewife
um I think that's beautiful and so
that's what I think identifies a good
woman okay
um what about you well identifying as a
good woman nowadays is a bit difficult
however I would emphasize on the values
and uh the morals of the woman
um primarily her ability to be a good
wife her ability to raise good children
and even her thoughts and the things she
has in mind because she's gonna be
molding the Next Generation and uh so
how does he know
well it can because you know women lie
like we can just say things like I'm
but you know if you have a deep
conversation with a person
but believe me throughout time you can
identify okay so how much how much time
if it's um I would say I would give it
like three months but it can okay so
three months of constant
um
con Center meeting
okay so you think in three months he can
see if she has traditional value yes
okay she would I mean just so healthy so
he can look she healthy and fit cool
yeah
um is she how can he test this she's
submissive
he can ask something and see the
reaction so ask her to do something and
see what she does for example you can
tell I mean as if a man tells to a woman
can you uh please make me a coffee or a
meal and she said hell no I'm not doing
this to you I mean that's all right
she's here for three months ask her to
make him a coffee
okay
[Laughter]
I'm just writing I'm writing what okay
uh what what else can he do how does he
act uh does he like what else what else
does he do I mean well uh because I was
here just find a good woman so I'm just
trying to get from the women how did the
men just find a good woman
yeah it's his ability to identify what
he values in in a woman okay I mean
that's gonna be subjective to an extent
yeah so I'm asking like what what makes
someone a good woman and how does he
identify that I think what you were
saying is Well men do test women I've
been tested by men like with certain
things so like oh can you cook for me
can you make me food or like on the spot
though I asked to I don't know
it really happens you know it's a good
test it really happens and then he'll
know if do you know how to cook can you
cook properly properly even your
presentation
step by step further where I'm going to
let the men talk I'm just curious how
it's gonna align with what you guys say
from the women and the men
um okay so first he's got to see her for
three months ask her to make him a
coffee and ask to cook oh I disagree
with all of that I think that honestly
if it's a high value man most of the
time he's gonna know without all of that
honestly most of them nowadays how does
he know
um there is this I don't know if it's
the right word but there is this Aura
there is this
sense when you sit with a woman who you
know is going to be respectful to you or
not I honestly feel that I think that
average men just know this because
you're talking about high value that's
like yeah that's like five percent I
know but but average man nowadays look
at high value men's content more and
more and more okay and try to see so you
think and I think you think I'm just
curious you think men just know
they don't just know but they should get
to a point
to just know so they they have so how so
how does he get to that point that he
just knows
well slowly slowly slowly we're getting
to a point where I think they need to go
to certain parts of the world to know
and certain parts of the world they will
just know that 90 of the women will not
be like that and okay so he has to he
needs to travel too slowly we're getting
he needs to travel somewhere else and
then experience those women and then
compare exactly exactly okay but for for
a guy that doesn't travel like he stays
in the west because most remember most
guys don't make a ton of money like I
think half of uh us men don't have
passports yeah so so most men aren't
traveling like that so for God it's not
traveling how does he know good woman
versus bad woman I would say if you if
the first conversation with her is like
oh so where are we going to dinner are
we having drinks this is not a right way
to to meet I think when you meet a girl
you should take her for coffee and
that's it even if you like her so much
that you take on a coffee date and see
what she's like and see if she these I
don't know if she wants to continue the
date and get you to buy her dinner and
can a man know a good woman from a bad
woman without experiencing a lot of
women
no not really okay so so in order to
identify he asked what
uh he I would suggest that in in his 20s
he dates as many women as he can that's
right that's what okay okay so so how
many women should he date
date as many women as possible to tell
the difference I read it because again
remember I just want to remind everybody
the stats one out of three women has an
STD one out of three women has had an
abortion 38 percent of women are of kids
are born into single parent homes
meaning 38 of the Next Generation has
never seen a functioning marriage
um average child first child is before
the average age of first marriage so
their first kid 26 first marriage 30
half of marriages will end in divorce
average number of partners for a woman
is between four and eight
um and
that's self-reported so you know take
that with a grain of salt but women have
a 20 chance of being in a happy marriage
if they have slept with more than five
people so
um yeah and if men get divorced they can
be financially ruined and their kids can
be taken from them um 70 of women are
overweight so basically there's a lot
riding on them picking the right woman
so I'm trying to give them a foolproof
plan
that makes sense there's a book that I
read called sex a Dawn and in this book
they were making a case basically for a
polyamory A polyamorous relationships
which I don't resonate with personally
but I was trying to convince myself
because everyone else seems to think
that's a good idea except for me so I
thought well I gotta read this book but
at the end of the book they had a very
interesting fact about the olfactory
um sense right your nose that actually
we sniff each other out
a woman can tell if a man will
compliment her differences genetically
I've heard that yeah and then but a
woman actually can't if she's taking
birth control
oh it's disabled but a man can actually
sniff her out he can genetically
identify through his olfactory you know
sense through his nose whether or not
she'll complement his genetic weaknesses
so how does he know what does he have to
smell for I don't know that's a good
question
but apparently it's like a deep very
primal thing about so maybe attraction
maybe make sure she's not on birth
control yes right for example not on
birth control I think that works both
ways now I wonder what percent hold on I
wanna I just want to look up because I'm
curious what percent of women are on
birth control also who hears on birth
control raise your hand no one not
anymore I mean clearly one out of three
are having abortion so I'm like it can't
be that high
uh the majority uh but oh 90 of women
have used conscious deceptives
throughout their reproductive years
um and have used more than one in their
lifetime 76 percent
wow okay we just have a good room I
guess I'm gonna add that to my stats
okay
um sorry can I just add one more thing
that came to my mind
um ask her about the family you know
sometimes I do understand that not all
of the parents can stay together of
course there are special situations but
just see how she talks about her family
what is her relationship like with her
family and her her Dad too you know so
if a girl even if a girl is not in on
good terms with her dad but she
disrespects him by talking trash to a
guy that's not a girl that you should
marry honestly and if I don't think you
can disagree with this because there's
no even if you haven't got a great
relationship with your or your father's
absent it doesn't mean that the woman is
going to be a wreck it is
why do we have the phrase daddy issues
if it doesn't mean anything but some
most people will not okay a lot of
people that have daddy issues and we
don't know who they are I'm one of them
but I'm not a disrespectful person to
men like I'm not well yeah we're not
talking about you but in general like
it's your dad no matter what like I
think if you've never if you've never
seen a healthy relationship how would
you know how to do it exactly like if
I've never seen anyone ride a bike how
would I learn to ride a bike it's common
sense I feel like it's like morality if
it was common then why do half of
relationships end in divorce and why is
the older generation known for being so
unhappy in their marriages because men
pick women based off the off the surface
they don't actually get uh get to find a
deeper meaning if women swipe right on
dating apps which is the most
superficial only five percent of the
time immense vibrate fifty percent of
the time who's more superficial men or
women women but mostly men are hoes
that's incorrect one out of three men
are either virgins or haven't had sex I
feel like I'm not going to sleep around
one out of one out of three men are
either virgin or haven't had sex in the
past year wow I think a lot of women
sleep around so yeah a lot of women do
sleep right now
so what are you saying we're the same
yeah it's like 20 of men are [__] all
the girls essentially in their 20s and
then when women hit 30 they'll expand it
like basically like women typically go
for looks in their 20s
um women pick like when women this is
the first time in history where women
have been the sexual selectors so like
historically think about it you had to
get along with the dude or you die
like they would pay they would pick you
you wouldn't pick them uh but now this
is the first time where women have been
100 in control of reproduction because
we have birth control we're in control
of abortion so we are 100 in control of
who's born and it's funny because the
more freedom women get the more we screw
the same people in our Prime which is
like 22 to 24
um they surveyed men between like 20 and
80 and they said when do you find women
most attractive it's like roughly 22 to
24 all the ages think that so when women
have the most Choice it's interesting
because we pick non-monogamy
and we and we tend to go for looks and
women react out of emotion yeah solely
out of emotion a lot of the time which
is why you see so many women sleeping
with so many men and making decisions on
the spot that aren't responsible like
abortion yeah so majority of women not
going for men that's not monogamous then
why they fight for man to be monogamous
I mean I think they want him to be but
so they want to change the man basically
they see a man
they're gonna put a top 20 or whatever
which they know is they can tell that he
gets a lot of girls or whatever yeah so
they want to try and lock down that one
man so you don't yeah okay I mean I
think that's like every girl's you know
it has a you know what Cinderella was
sitting at home and the prince like came
and picked her out of all the princesses
exactly they want to say I was the one
who changed him they've been selling us
this dream forever exactly exactly
um so what do you what do you think of
that does that change your perspective a
little bit
um
not right kinda not really no okay what
does it not change I just still think
that
um
men are looking for things they don't
have themselves they look they don't
have the minerals for the things that
they want and the women so they just
pick women based off looks they don't
know what they want anyway like they
think they know what they want but they
haven't even got the minerals anyway is
it possible that women don't have what
they want absolutely right absolutely
how would they pick it if the dating
pool has like one out of every three
women's had an abortion one of every
three women has an STD
um like 38 40 grew up without a dad so
they don't have that model like how
would they where how would they know
yeah who good woman is yeah like they've
never like what percent of men have like
even seen a true traditional woman I
don't think yeah do you know any women
with like recipe books
ever is nice nice too but only like the
upper class High celebrity profile
people yeah and then these two now yeah
okay and my whole family and then when I
go there they're like oh so modern you
know everyone still Cooks the same meals
and so
um but so I'm just curious like when
you're hearing these stats like assuming
I'm telling you the truth you don't
think like it puts more of the
promiscuity on women because we're only
sleeping with 20 of men
um so like that means 80 of us are
um